[Music]
as a spiritual successor to banjo
kazooie ukulele really does capture the
cheeky personality of its predecessor it
doesn't introduce many new ideas but it
does rework the existing formula
creating a more open and far less linear
version of the n64 collectathon
ultimately though bloated levels and a
largely uncooperative camera keep
ukulele from being more than just a
nostalgia trip the adventure begins when
corporate president capital B steals
yuca and Laelius golden pages so of
course you have to enter his building to
get them back that hub area Highbury
towers listen to five steamed worlds but
the themes aren't terribly original for
banjo games or games in general and like
in banjo you have a variety of
collectables to find wherever you go
from pay G's to currency like coils to
power up ukulele is about finding
collectables first and foremost and
platforming takes somewhat of a backseat
there is more than one page e unlocked
by playing around a skull several found
by completing races and many hidden
behind simple memory puzzles to name a
few that's actually a good thing because
the camera is often very uncooperative
it locks into place at seemingly random
points and even swings wildly in tough
spots making the platforming challenges
that are they're terribly frustrating
and time-consuming
[Music]
when most of your time goes toward the
collectibles that are the least fun to
get that the problem once I unlock the
ability to fly for a limited periods of
time I started cheating completely to
get around platforming I didn't want to
do I most consistently enjoyed the hub
world where the power of collectibles
are hidden in clever spots and the pages
are locked behind challenging puzzles
that make good use of ukuleles moveset
and strategies you pick up in the actual
world of course the fact that the hub
area stands out isn't a good thing for
the rest of you Glalie each of the
levels can be expanded once which is a
new take on the formula and you can
visit each of them in pretty much any
order you want that open structure makes
for a steady pace since you don't have
to stay stuck on a page your puzzle you
can move on to another world where you
might learn a move or strategy that will
help you elsewhere that also makes
returning to a world you've already
visited more rewarding when you found 20
of the 25 pages in the world and we're
sure there was nothing else you could
possibly do to find the rest coming back
to that area with fresh eyes and new
abilities under your belt and seeing
what you didn't before is its own
special kind of achievement the other
update to the banjo formula of being
able to expand worlds is less successful
each of the base worlds is clearly
incomplete but expanding them doesn't
necessarily improve them because most of
them have additions in multiple areas
and directions their layouts are hard to
follow and it can be tedious just to
figure out where you haven't been yet
the snow level in particular is broken
up into a bunch of areas that connect in
bizarre ways and even after several
hours exploring it I'm not entirely sure
which caves connect to which part twenty
hours of hunting collectibles and
fighting simple bosses later I had found
the bare minimum amount of pages to move
on to the end of the game and couldn't
justify finding any more than that the
ones I had left were not worth either
the time it would take or the
frustration I'd have to endure to get
them I stayed as long as I did because
of my own nostalgia although there
aren't references outright ukelele has
plenty of banjo parallels the lizard and
bat duo are nearly identical in
personality to Banjo and Kazooie with
lately making the majority of the snarky
comments and Yuka being the voice of
reason
on top of that the collectibles and
moves are very similar in function to
their counterparts in the banjo games
and the music features many of the same
familiar motif but ukulele also lacks
new ideas and the twist introduces or
entirely successful ultimately ukuleles
best and worst aspects come directly
from its predecessor if you're looking
for a faithful return to the banjo
kazooie formula ukulele certainly
delivers from the fonts the menus to the
music it's worthy of the title of
spiritual successor but despite attempts
at modernizing the formula its style of
gameplay is still outdated and it
doesn't stay challenging or interesting
for long because
[Music]